you don't have a choice
you know if you want to work for caesar
anyhow
a bushwhacker is like a robin hood
steals from the rich that gives to the
poor okay you know what i mean
and they did they did a thing like that
with mick jaggers
in australia that movie i forget the
name of it
but that's what he was you know
uh a bushwicker so there is so there you
are that's
the name of that so he kept bringing us
up and
at the time which which was exploding on
television
was um crocodile crocodile dundee
yeah and that so all the vignettes were
around like that you know driving on the
wrong side of the road
and and talking and that and we did a
lot of vignettes
and that crazy ones going going to a
drink machine and putting
you know and shaking the machine saying
how do we get these drinks out
and people on the street say oh you
dropped put quarters and
then the candle come out and how do you
open them
and i took out my teeth and popped them
with my teeth you guys are just kind of
like cavemen
yeah caveman and that you know what i
mean yeah and doing all sorts of stuff
and
and then we asked the guy how to for
directions
and we turn around and butchers oh these
americans are great
they they even tell you where to go you
know but
we'll put it the way they tell you to
[ __ ] off you know what i mean
yeah yeah the way and we did a lot of
vignettes you know
went into restaurants and that and they
served the stuff we ordered the whole
menu
and we threw away the knives that we we
ate from down under
you know with our hands and that and all
that sort of stuff we did a lot of and
yes
so by the time we got a month was over
that seed we'd done every time we flew
up we did two or three different
vignettes
wow so um for a month we did 12
vignettes
and then when did you guys get into it
and then then they called us up
and we started on the road and um at the
start
we were we we didn't um he never gave us
the arm swinging or the head licking we
came up with all that
because the moon dogs we said butch said
to me he says
the moon dogs were on been on usa
network
for the last five years and we've been
on in
on turner network on and off from
79 to 88 so
let's create something different and
when we were
when we were working until turner's
studios
we every time we went outside the ring
would swing up our arms
and go whoa you know what i mean to
scare the people you know what i mean
we go out there wow and that and um
so he said let's go let's start swinging
our arms going to the ring
so that's how we got the march and then
we added the lick
which i grabbed the head but i always
licked the back of my hand
you know what i mean yeah you know what
it was looking butch got staffed later
on
that's why he got real sick you got
staff oh yeah okay
we'll get to that he died he died twice
he died twice
nearly died twice yeah from licking
heads well he got staph infection
and that it could have been from licking
but it all could have been from a thing
a liniment called dmso
which they use for horses and heals it
heals torn
ligaments and muscles overnight you know
you rub it on
and that and you and it goes with dmso
and it's very strong
you know you can you can you can put it
in your hand
and use the thing a sound ultrasound
under here
and it'll bubble in your hand it's you
know
it goes right through and that a lot of
people have used that
if you've got bacteria on your hair and
you rub it and you've got a scratch
that'll take it right to the bone so we
don't know that
he got the star from that or it was
looking you know sweaty
it's working it's sweating and that you
know and all different people because
he used to grab them and give them a
lick yeah i mean
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] that dirty
ass [ __ ] man
yeah anyhow um so anyhow that's how
we went through that we after about a
month we got our gimmick down pat
you know our marching and that yeah and
now we're in arena as soon as we start
our music come on
everyone will be standing and doing this
yeah i mean
and even on nfl guys would go behind the
line for a touchdown
and then you know you know and do the
march yeah that'd be the marching that
that's how hot it got over yeah march in
the late 80s that got over happy
and it still when i went to when i was
working on sunday
you know i come out of march all the
people are swinging their arms up
standing
you know as soon as they hear the music
the wrestling fans
right they know it thanks thank god
thanks to wwe network
they play all our old stuff yeah they've
never got a they've even got our sheep
hurt us we're
we're we're all bad guys yeah look at
all that stuff you know the network's
got
all the stuff on that's the that keeps
it that keeps office alive
right yeah every time they do the royal
rumble which is the pay-per-view in
january
they always show the one that i was
throwing as i got up on the apron
um earthquake
grabbed me and that and um it took me
over the ring and
and went out and i as soon as i landed i
just started marching yeah i saw that
video
that been that's been played since 1992
every year what's the most amount of
money you ever made wrestling is there
like one match that made you the most
money ever
what was that week what was the best
week you ever had [ __ ] i don't know mate
i can't
just like estimate just rough it's not
to be exact
biggest fleet 10 or 12 grand
10 or 12 gr grand yeah wow how many
matches did you have to do that week
a full week four week every day no i've
made more than that but
you know that's the biggest one in a
pay-per-view that's the biggest payoff
i got a pay-per-view okay yeah
damn and then what was like your biggest
match was like the peak match that you
okay there's two different ones that'll
remember
for a lifetime and that is the first one
is the
wembley stadium in london the old
wembley stadium
the last show before they pulled it down
to build the new one
we butchered me and hacksaw duggan were
against the nasty boys
and the mountie there was 94
600 people there and we were we were the
first match to
to get the people out you know the crowd
had been sitting there
and that first match was a big thing
yeah because if the first match sucks
the crowd's down for and it's hard to
get them back you know i mean
we walked out there and that was the
people were [ __ ] on fire
you know that you know because you know
what should i
watching a football match there's you
know how many's living on the side isn't
there
how many you know in the football team
your football teams
you have how many people on a football
team no there's like there's like 20 or
30 i thought
yeah on the field at once oh no no no no
no no yeah i don't know i don't know you
know
but now but when you're in the ring
there's only six of us
in that ring right and you've got all
those people looking at you
you remain out of your single match you
know i've been
a lot of them who have been in tags me
and butch and it's been 76
000 but that was that was the biggest
full one the biggest for me was 94 6.
walking out there the aura
the tension yeah it's gotta feel crazy
it's just [ __ ]
mind-blowing you know i mean and you
don't have to do nothing
you just have to go whoa and the whole
people go whoa
you go yay they said it was me and butch
go woe and yay
and hex with duncan go oh so that it was
[ __ ] wild
and that we could have done that all
night and not have today
to do any action yeah we did some we did
some wild stuff
you know we didn't have to do much
because the people were there
they were just they were just loving it
yeah it's in
being the first match and that you know
since then
there's been you know they did a hundred
and four thousand
in texas stadium three three uh
wrestlemanias ago
that was how many 104
yeah in the texas stadium i went to my
first wrestlemania last year i think it
was last year maybe it was two years ago
it was in new orleans yeah i was there
yeah that was the first wrestlemania i
ever went to and it was
i did not expect it to be that insane
because i'd only watched wrestling
matches on tv before that yeah and when
i got there i luckily i got like
i got like four seats i was maybe like
eight rows back on the floor
and and uh dana white was actually like
a few rows in front of me
yeah and just the [ __ ] the show the
fire and the lights
and everything was just so over the top
the the the thing that stood out to me
the most was the undertaker's intro
with everything like out of nowhere the
whole stadium just goes black
and then it's just like that that gun
sound that [ __ ] that bell goes off
and then
the light shines down on him it just it
[ __ ] made my hair it made my hair
stand up
you don't have to be a wrestler like the
ultimate warrior
you know he was a bodybuilder stop
eating he was a bodybuilder
and that and um he didn't care about the
wrestling and that
but the smoke and mirrors and him
running to the ropes and shaking the
ropes shaking the road
that's all he had to do because he
couldn't do god bless him
up there but um he didn't have to do
much more you know what i mean
yeah and that's smoke and mirrors
they do a great [ __ ] job with the
smoke and mirrors though
hey the pyro and the and
the lighting and uh insane
i